[Music]
foreign
then for the Press preview it's a first
chance to check out tomorrow's front
pages and tonight we'll take a look at
the headlines with the editor-in-chief
of the national World Cities Newspaper
group Nancy Fielder and the acting
Deputy political editor of the mail on
Sunday Claire Ellie kott so good to see
you this bank holiday Monday evening
thanks for joining us let's have a look
at those front pages first though shall
we ahead of tomorrow's NHS strike action
the Metro asks is there a doctor in the
house
according to the I some 350 000
appointments and operations are likely
to be canceled far more than was
originally forecast
while the express advises its readers
not to get ill
the mirror lead with details of Junior
doctors pay which it says works out to
be as little as 14 pounds an hour
the times is expecting disruption to the
NHS for up to a month
while the guardian says the action by
Junior doctors could run until the
general election which may not happen
until January 2025.
here's the telegraph it's looking ahead
to President Biden's visit to Ireland
tomorrow and says he'll try to break the
deadlock over the suspended government
at Stormont
while the male claims an exclusive in
news that 19 terrorist aspects have been
found among migrants crossing the
channel in small boats while the Ft has
news of successful debuts for a number
of companies on Chinese stock exchanges
and the star tells us that astronauts
May soon be given the tools to
manufacture their own medicines in space
and as always a quick reminder that you
can scan the QR code that you see on
screen that you're in the Press preview
and you can take a look at the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and to do that
I'm joined by Nancy Fielder and Claire
Ellicott so let's get stuck in shall we
um tomorrow morning the junior doctors
strike begins of course and I have to
say just having a glance at all the
front pages it paints a pretty negative
picture doesn't it Nancy of what's going
to happen
yeah I mean lots and lots of people
they're suggesting as many as 350 000
they're going to have the treatments
their operations their appointments
canceled because of this but actually
let's be completely honest tens of
thousands are missing out on the NHS
treatment already and this is not just
about a large pay increase that has been
demanded by the junior doctors this is
about an NHS that has got so many
vacancies that it can't fill and no sort
of sign of any hope around this so it is
going to be really really Grim but if
the junior doctors aren't fighting for
our NHS and demanding better so that we
can recruit new generations into it who
is going to so I think it's going to be
tough this I'm not sure there's quite
the level of public sympathy for junior
doctors as there is for nurses but I
hope people will understand why they're
doing and it's not just about pay yeah
Nancy there doesn't seem to be a huge
amount of sympathy does there on the
front pages
um and 35 percent is a pretty big pay
Rise um to be asking for isn't it
it is it's an enormous pay rise but I
think we all assume that doctors are a
lot better paid than they are
particularly Junior doctors and I was
having a conversation with a junior
doctor's wife and a 17 year old boy who
was looking at medicine and she was
telling him it was absolutely horrific I
know many Junior doctors who wouldn't
advise people to follow in their
footsteps because working for the NHS is
absolutely awful and it's terrible
because people whose vocation it is to
care for people have been driven out of
the NHS and can't do the job and can't
give the care they want to give so it's
a big number but actually it's got to be
about more than that it is about the
care that they can give and the
conditions we expect our doctors to work
in okay front page of the eye Claire
their headline thousands more patients
than expected won't be treated due to
the doctor's strike they're talking
about as we've been hearing up to 350
000 operations and appointments now
expected to be canceled over the next
few days what's your take on it
what's the Staggering number of
operations that are going to be canceled
and we already have seven million people
on the waiting list
um due to the backlog from covid so
patients can be hit really really hard
you've got a four day walkout plan this
week there was a three-day walk out last
month which caused loads of problems I
think it was 175 000 operations were
canceled last month this month it's
going to be more like 350 000 as we were
saying and and that's going to have a
huge huge impact on patient care and I
think what Nancy was saying about the
public having less sympathy for doctors
I think that's true nurses have a
particular place than the Public's
infection but I think people assume that
doctors are well paid and while
Consultants are when they get to the
more senior levels Junior doctors aren't
always but to ask for a 35 pay rise at a
time like now where most people are
struggling to pay their bills and are
really struggling to make ends meet it
does seem like a staggeringly high
amount whether or not it's a negotiating
position and I think the Union's a
warning that this these walkouts are
going to carry on and that they've been
time to coincide with bank holidays and
that they may run until for the next
year maybe until the next election now I
think the public are going to really
struggle with that this is going to have
a huge impact on patient care and if you
don't have the public on side there's
far less incentive for ministers to
compromise over their pay yeah but do
you think Claire that ministers are
compromising you know is the government
even even coming to the table I mean 35
does seem a huge amount but anyone who's
ever done any sort of negotiation
overpay will know that that you've got
to start high
well I think what's interesting is that
the government has let a lot of these
strikes run on for quite a while and um
has come to a settlement with nurses and
with some other NHS workers and they're
the ones the public have the most
sympathy for and they've they've got you
know a bonus they've got a five percent
real-time pay rise and um in the face of
that the BMI BMA asking for a huge rise
to doctors doesn't quite look the same
but you know the the negotiations with
teachers are ongoing there's other
negotiations ongoing and the possible
services and and the trains and I think
that you know doctors are not going to
have the same potential effect as some
of those other striking workers
um that said you know this is going to
have a huge impact and it will come down
to who the public blame whether the
public blame ministers or whether they
blame the Striking doctors for this huge
backlog in care and the fact that
they're having their operations canceled
and people are being told not to engage
in Risky Behavior and to um think twice
before phoning 999 unless they're in a
life-threatening situation I mean
they're not the kind of warnings that
you know doctors unions want to be
putting out and you know the public
wants to be hearing is quite a fraught
situation I think it'll have a real
effect this week yeah and you you
mentioned uh warnings to the public The
Daily Express uh going with that in its
headline don't get ill exclamation mark
doctors strike going to her Nancy is it
time for a cast to step in do you think
the the the the conciliation service do
we need a bit of help from them
we'd need some help from somebody don't
we I mean it does feel like in all these
strikes the government has played
Hardball in fact it's played like
children arguing in a playground and if
you turn your back put your fingers in
your ears and ignore it let it go on for
as long as you possibly can and cause as
much disruption as possible so the
public turns against the people that it
needs because let's be honest if we
don't have Junior doctors who are we've
got enough energy to work who aren't
working those shifts that they say
they're not safe by the end of the shift
if we don't have people who are paid and
want to do that job and are willing to
stay in that job for their career then
we've got real trouble and the
government just it's playing a game
isn't it it's seeing if the public gets
fed up first it's seeing who blinks
first and it's quite childish we need to
really sit down definitely need to get
across in or maybe some sort of
superhero because I don't see the
government really giving any of the
right noises at the minute yeah an NHS
superhero I wonder I wonder who that
would be Claire I mean do you think do
you think Nancy's right we need we need
some help from a Cass
well yes I'm sure it will be a great
intervention but um I imagine that the
government is partly waiting for as
Nancy says to see how the public take it
to see which side it all falls on
because there is you know there is a
bigger picture than this which is that
paying you know increasing public sector
wages does have an effect on inflation
and that is something the government are
really worried about is one of Rishi
sudak's key priorities to halve
inflation and before the next election
and so they are not going to be Keen to
be giving huge pay Rises
um to choose public sector workers at
the moment and but I think there's
another element of this which is
um you know a lot of these a lot of
these um claims that you know that that
doctors and other public sex workers are
underpayers are based on the fact that
there is a cost of living crisis that
um you know their their wages aren't
keeping up with the real times real
times cost of things and um I think that
as the economy starts to improve little
by little we haven't entered the
recession things looking slightly better
the projections look slightly better
there is a possibility that you know the
economic arguments sort of um Fades a
little bit and you know the public
sector workers and the unions will have
to come to a maybe a more a lower
agreement than they would have done um
if they'd have negotiated at the height
of you know inflation running at 10 11
it's interesting isn't it how the
teachers and the junior doctors are both
saying that as much as this is about
money it's also about Recruitment and
Retention and a crisis in both those
sectors okay let's move on then uh to uh
a story that's covered in in all the
papers we're looking at the inside of
the metro and this is these attack ads
Nancy by label what do you make of them
I'm not
a particular thing we've spent the last
last season's just
sniping at each other and not actually
really discussing the issues that matter
they don't seem to sort of fall out
about policies and sort of talk about
actually what they can do to make things
better we're in a cost of living crisis
partially created by politicians and the
party that's been in charge for over a
decade but I'm not sure these are
helping people these and this is not a
sort of debate that's really getting
anybody talking about what the policy
should be what changes we need how we
help a country that I mean we've just
been talking about the NHS you mentioned
the teacher strikes there's so much that
needs solving and I don't think this is
helping at all this is just it's
politicians sniping like they do and I
think it does it doesn't do anybody else
the answer is that this has been going
on for decades centuries even
well unless of us vote every time
there's an election because we're all so
sick of it you're absolutely right but
they don't seem to be able to change and
every time you get a new prime minister
or even a new party you get the promises
that it's all going to be different and
actually let's be honest it never feels
completely different does it never feels
particularly hopeful and I think that
they're just they're wide of the Mark if
people aren't coming out and been
positive and all we can do is complain
that the others are worse than us no
wonder the voting figures fall and
Claire it's interesting the divisions in
the labor party itself isn't it you know
kirst armor and others saying that
they're absolutely sticking with it
whereas others John McDonald David
blanket Etc have been saying this is
this is a new low
but I think that's what's really
interesting it's really polarized the
labor party and the shadow cabinet as
well as the kids Summer's most senior
um senior Shadow ministers are massively
divided over this and we have a vet
Cooper at home the shutter Home
Secretary saying at the weekend that she
hadn't well for sources saying that she
hadn't signed any of this off and um I
think Emily Thornbury
um has been to the shadow of attorney
general has been trying to defend it but
it's not really she's not really being
that convinced so
um Kia stalmers written a piece in the
daily mail actually saying that he has
zero apologies for the approach
um but it's what's interesting is that
it really has divided people because
um Labor's argument is that being nice
doesn't win elections you know you have
to go on the attack and actually the
great thing about this approach is that
everybody's talking now about Rishi
soonax and his is you know all the crime
that's happened under him this was
specifically about sexual assaults and
people imagine people being jailed and
that labor wins on initially and what
they've done is they're now doubling
down on this so they're going to have
further attacks on and the the cost of
living crisis on the economy and the
role that Rishi sunak supposedly played
in this now there are some real problems
or if you say it wasn't even an MP when
some of these sentencing problems
happened whereas here starma was
actually in charge of the sentencing
board for on the sentencing board for
some of that time so there is a really
strange sort of attack but and I think
Labor's position is that we get people
talking about this people notice it they
start to think that crime is bad onto
the Tories and um they turn to labor but
I think perhaps it's backfires a little
bit his some of the the people on his
team are not very happy with it and like
you say some really key labor people are
really unhappy with it so it's you know
if they carry on top legs out we'll see
but it doesn't seem like a greatly
sensible attack um position from my
perspective